[موسيقى]
الحصاد معكم جلال شهد في الوقت الذي
احدثكم في احداث تقع
وتتفاعلوا اخرى هذه الصور مباشره من قطاع
غزه في محيط القطاع اعلن الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه للصاروخ فيما دوه صفارته
مريم
في خلال في خلاف غزه
من باكستان هذه صور جاءت قبل قليل
الاحتجاجات مستمره بعد محاوله اغتيال
عمران خان
في مواضيع الحصاد
مخيم وجنين على واقع اقتحام جديد قوات
الاحتلال تقتل فلسطينيين احدهما قيدي في
سرايا القدس وتشتبك مع مسلحين وفي القدس
الاحتلال يؤكد اصابه ثلاثه من جلوده في
حادثه طعن ويعلن قتل المنفذ صفارات
الانذار تدوي في مستوطنات غلاف غزه والجيش
الاسرائيلي يقول ان القبه الحديديه اعترضت
صاروخا اطلق من القطاع واعلانه فوزي معسكر
اليمين بزعامه نتنياهو يفتح باب التكهنات
بشان مستقبل التصعيد
في باكستان فشلوا محاوله اغتيال رئيس
الوزراء السابق عمران خان خلال تجمع
لاصاله في اقليم البنجاب للمطالبه
بالانتخابات المبكره حزب انصاف يقول ان
احد المهاجمين اوقف بعد مقتل الاخر وزير
الداخليه يطالب بتقديم تقرير فوري عن
الحادث
[موسيقى]
واستغ غموض يخيم على التطورات الميدانيه
في خرسان السلطات الاوكرانيه تقول ان
القوات الروسيه تعيد موضوعها في المقاطعه
الى جنوب نهر النيبرو وتخفض عدد جنودها
وتفكك مشاهده طبيه ومتاحف والقوات الروسيه
والمواليه لها تقول انها اعترضت صواريخها
اوكرانيه وصدت هجمات في خرسانه ودمرت
مستودعا للاسلحه وزير الدفاع الامريكيه
يقول ان الاوكرانيين قادرون على السعاده
خرسان من روسيا
صواريخه في الاتجاهين خلال اقل من 24 ساعه
كوريا الشماليه تطلق 13 صاروخا بارسيا
باتجاه بحر اليابان وتقيض سقوط اثنين
منهما في البحر سول تقول انها ردت بثلاثه
صواريخ جو ارض وباعلان تمديد مناوره جويه
مشتركه هي الاكبر من نوعها مع واشنطن دعوه
دوليه مجلس الامن وبجين تدعوا الى استئنا
في الحوار
في لقائنا اليوم قبل الحصاد على من
السلطنه الرقميه ناقشنا محاوله اغتيال
عمران خان رئيس الحكومه المقال من منصبه
والذي نجى بعد تعرضه لاطلاق نار اثناء
زياره كان ينظمها مع قياده حزبه الى مدينه
وزير اباد باقليم الفنجان ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي برايكم
هل ستفتح محاوله اغتيال عمران خان الباب
على اضطرابات اوسع في المشهد السياسي
الباكستاني 60% قالوا انها ستؤدي لتعقيد
في حين قرار 40% ان المشهد سيبقى على حاله
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصات الرقميه
يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو
ار الظاهري على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
خلال الحصاد ستتابعون مقابله خاصه اجتها
مع الدكتور انطوني فوتشي المستشار الطبيه
الاول للرئيس الامريكي وحوار بشان كورونا
وجودري القرود وعدد من الاوبئه التي يجري
حديث عن هذه الايام
اذا في اخبار عاجله وردت قبل قليل على جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يتلاقى صفرات الانذار
في بلدنا ريم والعين الثالثه وكيسه فين في
غلاف غزه مشيرا الى التفاصيل قيد البحث
وقالت هيئه البث الاسرائيليه ان مستوطنين
يعيشون في غلاف غزه يبلغون عن سماعهم
اصواتهم في جارات الناجمه عن اعتراضات
من القدس ماذا تقول الروايه الاسرائيليه
نعم جلال الجيش الاسرائيلي اعلنا قبل قليل
بان منظومه القبه الحديديه اعترضت صاروخا
واحدا في سماء غلاف غزه هذه الليله اطلق
من داخل قطاع غزه كما اشار الجيش
الاسرائيلي رغم ان شهود عيان في المنطقه
الوسطى لقطاع غزه ابلغ عن وقوع سلسله من
الانفجارات او على الاقل صنعوا انفجارين
او اكثر ربما يكون ذلك صدى صدى الناجم عن
التفجيرات عن اعتراض القبه الحديديه
للقذيفه الصاروخيه لكن بطبيعه الحال قوات
الجيش الاسرائيلي تقوم بعمليه تمشيط واسعه
في تلك المنطقه للوقوف على ما اذا كانت
اكثر من صاروخ قد اطلق بالفعل باتجاه
المنطقه الوسطى لغلاف غزه ربما تكون هنالك
بعض الصواريخ التي لم يجري اعتراضها قد
تكون سقطت في داخل القطاع غزه او في
مناطقه مفتوحه داخل الغلاف المنطقه
المستهدفه هي المنطقه تقع في وسط قطاع غزه
عند بلداته
وعيونهاشوشها وكيسوفين همم بطبيعه الحال
الجيش الاسرائيلي في هذه الحاله اعتمد
سياسه الرد على كل اطلاقا ل الصواريخ او
القذائف الصاروخيه باتجاه البلدات
الاسرائيليه هذا هذه السياسه متبعه منذ
سنوات وبالتالي من المرجح ان يقوم الجيش
الاسرائيلي في الساعات القليله القادمه
بتوجيه ربما ضربات واستهدافه مواقع تابعه
للجهاد الاسلامي تحديدا على اعتبار ان
مصادر امنيه تقول بان هنالك علاقه وثيقه
وارتباط بين اطلاقه هذا الصاروخ باتجاه
اسرائيل هذه الليله وبين عمليه الاغتيال
التي استهدفت القيادي البارز في الجهاد
الاسلامي في مخيم جنين الشهيد فاروق سلامه
هو هذا همم اليوم لكن من الواضح بان
اسرائيل ربما لن تقدم على كسر قواعد
الاشتباك هذه الليله على اعتبار ان حكومه
التصريف الاعمال لم تعد مخوله بالقيام
بحرب او بمواجهه كبيره بعد ان خسر يير
لبيد السباق على رئاسه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه وائل الدحدوح من غزه وائل ما
المعلومات المتوفره لديكم
حتى الان الحديث يدور عن اطلاق صاروخ واحد
على الاقل او صاروخين انطلاقا من قطاع غزه
لكن كما جرت العاده لا يوجد اي بيانات
صدرت عن اي جهه من الفصائل الفلسطينيه هنا
في قطاع غزه ولا من غرفه العمليات
المشتركه ولا حتى من الدوائر الرسميه او
الجهات الرسميه هنا في القطاع تبلغ عن
وجود حوادث
وبالتالي ظل الامر مقتصرا على شهود العيان
الذين قالوا بانهم سمعوا اصوات انفجارات
وكانت هذه الانفجارات مصحوبه همم شهب في
السماء ويبدو انها ناجمه عن اطلاق القبه
الحديديه الاسرائيليه في محاوله لاعتراض
هذان الصاروخان واا بالتالي هذه المعلومات
المتوفره حتى الان لكن كان واضحا بان
الاوضاع ربما تتوتر عقب عمليه اغتيال
القياده في الجهاد الاسلامي فاروق سلامه
في جنين وكانت الجهاد الاسلامي قد اصدرت
ايه بيان عقب عمليه الاغتيال قالت بان هذه
العمليه سوف تفتح ابواب الجحيم على قاده
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وفق ما جاء في البيان
وقالت بان العمليه لن تكسر اراده كتيبه
جنين وانها سوف تستمر في المقاومه وهو وهي
الجمله ربما والعبارات التي
اشارت بان الجهاد الاسلامي يمكن ان ياتي
الرد من خارج قطاع غزه لكن كما يبدو اا
يعني هذا اطلاق هذه الصواريخ على الاقل
حتى الان تبعا لشهود عيال واضح بانه يمكن
ان يتبعه رد من جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
او ضربات في قطاع غزه سنواكب معكم
التطورات بطبعه الحال شكرا لكم وائل في
غزه والياس في القدس
هذه التطورات تاتي على واقع التطورات اخرى
في ضفه الغربيه حيث استشهد فلسطينيان
واصيب اربعه بنران قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي عاقبه اقتحامها مخيمه جنين
وقال شهود عيانين ان وحده اسرائيليه خاصه
اغتالت الشاب فاروق سلامه احد قاده سرايا
القدس عند مدخل المخيم قبل ان تقتحمه قوات
الاسرائيليه معززه باليه عسكريه وتندلع
اشتباكات مسلحه مع مقاومنا فلسطينيين
[موسيقى]
قادتي كتيبه جنين وسرايا القدس الذراع
العسكريه للجهاد الاسلامي
تتهمه قوات الاحتلال بقتل ضابط اسرائيلي
في وحده اليمام قبل اشهر ومساعده مجموعه
عرين الاسود في نابلس
اكتشف المقاومون في المخيم والمدينه وحده
الكوماندوز فارسلت قوات الاحتلال تعزيزات
كبيره الى المخيم اطلقت الرصاصه الحي فقط
واصابت عددا اخر
فاندلعت اشتباكات عنيفه بين مقاومين
فلسطينيين والجنود الاسرائيليين العمليه
العسكريه في جنين تزامنت مع دخول وفد تروي
كدوليه الى نابلس عبر حاجز حواره بعد ما
رفعت قوه الاحتلال حصارا عن المدينه دام
ثلاثه اسابيع وفضل انضم اكثر من ثلاثين
الدبلوماسيه يمثلون الولايات المتحده ودول
الاتحاد الاوروبي ودول الغربيه برفقه رئيس
الوزراء الفلسطيني التقى الوفد برجال
اعمال وممثلين عن المجتمع المدني واكد انه
سيواصل جهوده لتقديم الدعم للفلسطينيين
في اقرب وقت ممكن جنين لانها مدينه تاثرت
ايضا بالاقتحامات والعنف لذلك نريد ان
نظهر تضامنا مع الشعب الفلسطيني ومعرفه ما
يمكننا القيام به لتحسين الوضع
اما السلطه الفلسطينيه فاكدت ان الزياره
رساله تؤكد وجوب انهاء الاحتلال وعمليات
القتل
ومطلوب من هذا الاحتلال ان يوقف جرائمه
بحق شعبنا ومطلوب منا جميعا ان نكون وحده
واحده ومطلوب منا ان ننهي انقسامنا
وبعد الصمود الشعبيه فك الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الحصار عن نابلس وضواحيها ولكن
لا يبدو ان الانتهاكات الاسرائيليات ستقف
عند هذا الحد لا سيما بعد وصول اليمين
الاسرائيلي المتطرف الى الحكم
ففي القدس المحتله قتل الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي فلسطينيا عند احد ابواب المسجد
الاقصى بزعم طعنه جنديا فيما اصيب جندي
اخر برصاص جميلا له
وفي بلده بدقه شيع الفلسطينيون جثمان
الشهيدين اخرين احدهما قتل عند حاجز عسكري
في قضاء رام الله بزعمده اسرائيلي وقتل
جيش الاحتلال الفلسطينيا كان داخل منزله
بعد اقتحام القريه
الجزيره نابلس
بان هذه التطورات السياسيه والامنيه تعطي
تاتي عفوا ايضا بعد مرحله طويله من الازمه
السياسيه التي عاشتها اسرائيل وقبل قليل
كما افدنا بانه هناك تطور في منطقه غلاف
غزه اسرائيلي يقول بان القبه الحديديه
اعترضت على الاقل صاروخا واحدا اطلق من
قطاع غزه من تل ابيب اور هيلر المراسل
العسكري للقناه الثالثه 10 الاسرائيليه
ابدا من هذا التطور حيث يقال الجيش
الاسرائيلي بانه همم تصدى لصاروخ واحد
اطلق من قطاع غزه
3 3
[موسيقى]
اشهر من الوضع الهادئ نسبيا في جنوب
اسرائيل وقطاع غزه بعد اخر عمليه ضد
الارهابيين بالجهاد الاسلامي في مساء هدمه
في التاسعه مساء بتوقيت اسرائيل
الارهابيون من جهاد الاسلامي اطلقوا
صاروخان على قرانا وعلى مستوطناتنا في
جنوب اسرائيل
يعني اللي هو همم
بطاريات قد
اسقطت هذه الصاروخ وهذا الرده التي قام به
جهاز اسلامي للعمليه العادله لاتقال بها
القوات الخاصه
والقوات الكوماندو الاسرائيليه في جنين
اذا سمحت ليست هذه رد فعل طبيعيه على
السياسه التي تتبعها اسرائيل في القدس وفي
الضفه الغربيه من قمع وقتل واختيالات
اعتقد
ان هذا
تكتيك يمارسها ارهابيين الجهاد الاسلامي
بعد
بعد ان تعرضوا
لمشاكل كبيره منذ الصيف الماضي
وهم الان يريدون ان يثبتوا انه ما زالوا
ارهاق
قطاع غزه
الارهابيين في غزه اسرائيل انهم لا يستطيع
ايقاف ارهابيه جهاد الاسلامي في في شمال
في الضفه الغربيه وفي جنين وفي نابلس
وطبعا هذه معادله همم جيش الدفاع لا يمكن
ان يقبلها وشهاده في منتصف الظهر في
الساعه الثانيه القوات الكوماندو
الاسرائيليه دخلت جنين همم
القبضه الامنيه التي تتبعها اسرائيل وهمم
كاسر الامواج الحمله التي تتبعها لانها لم
تاتي اكلها حتى الان العمليات الاسرائيليه
همم يعني تزداد في المقابل ايضا العمليات
فلسطينيه همم تزداد سواء كان تجاه الجيش
الاسرائيلي او مستوطن وهذا الصاروخ الاخير
ايضا من قطاع غزه باتجاه مناطق خلاف غزه
اسرائيل
افطرت ان تدخل في هذا العمليه كسر الامواج
بسبب الهجمات الارهابيه التي
تعرضنا هنا في تل ابيب وفل الارهابيون من
مخيم اللاجئين في جنين
كانوا جالسين في مقهى
واتناولنا الاشعه
وبالتالينا في تل ابيب وفي غيرها من
الاماكن وبالتالي اسرائيل
عمليه كسر الامواج لمحاربه الارهاب لا
خيار اسرائيل
الى تشكيل حكومه كيف كيف تتوقع ان يكون
تعاطي اسرائيل مع هذه الجمل
لو سمحت
على مستوى الامني لن تشهد
ان التغيرات كبيره فكما شاهدنا اثناء
سن 12
[موسيقى]
سنه
في لبنان ولم يبدا اي عمليات غير ضروريه
في قطاع
هو اوقف كثير عمليات في قطاع غزه وبالتالي
فاعتقد ان ما نشهده حاليا
همم
هو ما يمكن ان نقول انه
خطواتي المعتدله تتخذها اسرائيل
نواصل ذلك شكرا القادمه مساء تواصلنا هذه
حكومه
المراسل العسكري لقناه الثالثه عشر
الاسرائيليه شكرا لك من رام الله هاني
المصري مدير مركز مسارات لابحاث السياسات
والدراسات
تحدث عن الحكومه الجديده في اسرائيل وعن
التصعيد في الضفه الغربيه والقدس ولكن
اريد ان اسمع رايك اولا بهذا التطور من
قطاع غزه كيف تراه لو سمحت
اعتقد ان هذا التطور متوقع يمكن ان يكون
قد تاخر لان الضفه الغربيه تتعرض لعمليات
قتل واقتحام واعتقالات يوميه
وسقط وارتقى اكثر من 135 شهيدا منذ بدايه
هذا العام في الضفه الغربيه في نفس الوقت
التي تتواصل في اقتحامات المسجد الاقصى
وتهويد القدس والتوسع الاستيطاني اذا هناك
تصعيد كبير كان يقال انه بسبب الانتخابات
ولكن ما جرى بعد الانتخابات يدل على ان
هذه سياسه ثابته عند الحكومات الاسرائيليه
في محاوله دائما لكسر اراده الشعب
الفلسطيني على الصمود والمقاومه وفي كل
مره ينهض الشعب الفلسطيني من جديد ويستمر
في المقاومه لانه صاحب حق ولانه يتعرض لكل
انواع العدوان والضغط وليس مثل ما قال
يعني الضيف السابق بان اسرائيل لا تقوم
الا بخطوات معتزله
اتصال الاحتلال بحجزات وذروه الارهاب
الحصال لقطاع غزه هو شكل من اشكال الحرب
في حكم القانون الدولي وبالتالي كل هذه
المسائل تستدعي ردود فلسطينيه كنوع من
الدفاع عن النفس طيب ابقى معي همم
لنستعرض النتائج نتائج الانتخابات
الاسرائيليه حيث اكدت النتائج الرسميه
لانتخابات الاسرائيليه تحقيق معسكر اقصى
اليمين بزعامه بنيامين نتنياهو فوزا ساحقا
بحصوله على 64 مقعدا مقابله 51 مقعدا
لمعسكر التغيير بزعامه رئيس الحكومه
الرئيس الوزراء اتصالا لزعيم المعارضه بين
يمين الثانيه وهناء بفوزه في الانتخابات
وقالت وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه ان
نتنياهو باشرت اتصالاته مع الاحزاب
اليمنيه لتشكيل الحكومه الجديده سيدهني
حكومه جديده
وصفاتها ارتس بانها همم حكومه همم كهنه
يعني
مم- اقصى التطرف ماذا تتوقعون من حكومه
يراسها بنيامين الثانيه هو من الممكن ان
تضم
سموتريتش وبنكير
اعتقد ان نتائج الانتخابات الاسرائيليه
نقطه تحول تضاف الى نقاط التحول التي بدات
في عام 1977 عندما فاز اليمين يعني
الاسرائيلي لاول مره في الانتخابات
ومنذ ذلك الحين في معظم الانتخابات يفوز
اليمين ويتكرس بوصفه يمين اكثر تطرفا
ويمين ديني
وخططاته تتجه نحو همم تطبيق اقامه اسرائيل
الكبرى وبالتالي علينا ان نستعد لتصعيد
كبير عسكري وسياسي وعلى كل المستويات
والاصعده لان مشاركه يعني
كثير تعني ان التصعيد سيكون متعدد الاشكال
هو هذا ما صرحوا به مرارا وتكرارا يكفي ان
نعرف ان شعار الرئيسي في الحمله يعني كان
ملخصا في كلمه تيت تيت تعني ترانسفير
تهجير اذا هم يريدون ان طبقوا اا اقامه
اسرائيل الكبرى باسرع وقت وبشكل العنيف
حتى يقضوا على اي امكانيه للنهوض الشعب
الفلسطيني ولتحقيق حق تقرير المصير للشعب
الفلسطيني وبقيه حقوقه مثل حق العوده حقه
في المساواه حقي في العيش يعني مستقلا
اسوه ببقيه الشعوب في العالم شكرا السيد
هاني المصري مدير مركز مسارات لابحاث
السياسات والدراسات الاستراتيجيه
[موسيقى]
الى موضوع اخر شغل العالم اليوم نجى رئيس
الحكومه الباكستانيه السابق عمران خان من
محاوله اغتيال وذلك خلال تجمع لانصاره في
مدينه وزير اباد باقليم الانجاب وقال حزب
انصاف الذي يتزعم وهو عمران خان ان موكبه
تعرض لاطلاق نار ما ادى الى اصابته في
قدمه ونقل مراسل الجزيره عن مصدر في الحزب
ان احد مطلقيه النار قتل واعتقل اخر وقد
كان رئيس وزراء الباكستانيه شهباز شريف
محاوله اغتيال وطالبه وزير الداخليه
بتقديم تقريري عن الحدث
ثماني رصاصات اطلقت في لحظه سياسيه فارقه
في باكستان
[موسيقى]
المستهدفه رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان
اصيبه ولم يقتل
واستحاله من التخبط الشديد في موقع
الاعتداء نقل خان الى مستشفى حيث اجريت له
عمليه جراحيه لاستخراج شظايا رصاصه اصابت
قدمه
واكيد لكم انني مع بقيه القياده وحتى خان
بصحه جيده صحيح ان بيننا من اصابته شديده
وهناك قتيل واحد لكننا بخير
محاوله اغتيال رئيس الحكومه السابق وقادته
حزب انصاف الذي يتزحمه جرت في اثناء مسيره
احتجاجيه ما دفع الحكومه ليس لشجن
الاعتداء فحسب بل ولتحذير من تداعيته
يجب ان لا يتحول الميدان السياسي الى
ميدان دموي ونجذب اي محاوله تقوم بها اي
جهه لاغراق السياسه في الدماء ولابد ان
ناكد هنا ان رئيس الحكومه امر وزير
الداخليه وكل المسؤولين الامنيين في
البنجاب بالتحقيق وبشكل مفصل في الحادث
ون مع حزب انصاف المستهدف في الاعتداء
عبروا عن تضامنهم بوقفات احتجاجيه في اكثر
من مدينه وهو ما يعكس حاله الاستقطاب
الشديد المستمر في باكستان
في بلد تكررت فيه الجرائم السياسيه سيكون
لمحاوله اغتيال عمران خان تداعيات كبيره
ستزيد المشهد تعقيدا وستترك بلا شك اثرا
مباشره في الوضع السياسي والاقتصادي
والامني
عبد الرحمن مطار الجزيره اسلام اباد
تبقى
الاكاديمي والمحلل السياسي سيد ابو بكر
مدى واسع محاوله اغتيال عمران
[موسيقى]
سوف تكون على السيناريو السياسي لباكستان
خاصه انه استهدف في مسيره التي كانت متجهه
نحو اسلام اباد وكان يطالب من الحكومه
باجراء المنتخبات المبكره والان زادت
مطالبه الان يطالب
باستقاله الشخصيات الرمزيه من الحكومه وفي
نفس الوقت قد تزيد مطالبه عندما يبدا من
جديد مسيرته من نفس النقطه التي كان توقف
فيه اليوم
فبالتاكيد هذه الحادثه سوف تجعل الاوضاع
الامنيه اكثر تاكيدا في باكستان خاصه ان
هناك كان الصراع قائم بين عمران خان وبين
الحكومه الفيدراليه
من له مصلحه
سالتك عن الدوافع محاوله اغتيال يعني من
له مصلحه تصفيه عمران خان جسديا بعد ان
ابعد عن الحكومه اتفضل
همم بالتاكيد هناك دوافع موجوده معروفه
السياسيه من يستفيد ولكن في في هذا الوقت
وفي هذا التوقيت بالذات لنستطيع ان نحكم
همم من هو القائم بهذه العمليه ولكن
بالتاكيد الذي قام هو جاء الاوضاع الامنيه
والسياسيه لباكستان غير مستقره وهذا هو
وهذا هو سبب القلق لان الدافع قد يكون
السياسي قد يكون الشخصي قد يكون هناك دافع
من الخارج فكل هذه الدوافع يعني من بين
الاحتمالات كالاحتمال موجود ولكن لا
نستطيع ان نحكم ما لم تتم هناك تحقيقات
على ارض الواقع بالكامل وهمم يعني تنكشف
هناك كل همم
هذا الحادث هو هناك تصريحات المسؤولين همم
لانه هناك حكومه اقليميه فيدراليه فهناك
التصريحات متعارضه بعض الاحيان همم لانها
تصريحات مبدئيه فلا تكون هي ذكيه
في في نفس الوقت طيب فبالتاكيد هذه
الاشياء هي تتطلب بعض الوقت حتى تتضح
الصوره من السريعا سيد ابو بكر تابعنا
طبعا مظاهرات لانصار عمران خان احتجاجا
على محاوله اغتياله همم الى اين ستؤول
الامور في في باكستان بتقديرك بعد هذه
المحاوله الفاشله
بالتاكيد سوف تكون هناك هوشود غاضبه اكثر
وهي تتجه الى اسلام اباد كما اعلن عمران
خان انه سوف يتجه وهل ستتم هناك مفاوضات
وتنجح تلك المفاوضات بينه وبين الحكومه
الفيدراليه وهل تنجح هناك كل هذه
المحاولات السياسيه الامر يعود الى ذلك ان
لم تنجح فبالتاكيد هناك همم احوال تكون
نظريه في من ناحيه امنيه في اسلام ما بعد
وفي باكستان عموما لان طبعا هناك اثار
ومؤيد وامران اللي هم يعتبرون عمران خان
الخط الاحمر والخط الاخير شكرا تاكيد هم
سوف يخرجون الى الشوارع ويمارس
ابو بكر الصديق محل السياسي في اسلام ابا
شكرا لك
مين خلفيه اجتماعيات وثقافيه بعيده عن
السياسه جاء عمران خان المولود عام
1952 في مدينه لاهور عاصمه اقليم البنجاب
درس في بريطانيا ويحمل شهاده في الاداب
وعرف خالد البدايه كنجما رياضيا لامع قد
بلاده الى الفوز بكاس العالم في رياضه
الكريكيت عام 1992 سنوات قليله ثم يخضع
عمران خان اولى خطواته في عالم السياسه
حين اسس عام 96 حزب انصار مطلع الالفيه
الجديده دعم خان قائد الجيش مشرف خلال
استفتاء الشعبي تقلد بعده شرف رئاسه
الجمهوريه عام 2002 دخل عمران خان
البرلمان لاول مره و عام 2013 فاز حزمه في
الانتخابات المحليه بولايه خيبر وشكل بها
الحكومه المحليه ل 50 سنوات في عام 2018
فاز عمران خان وحزمه في الانتخابات العامه
وشكل الحكومه المركزيه رانيه بالتحالف مع
سته احزاب ونواب مستقلين واصبح رئيس
الوزراء الثاني والعشرين في تاريخ البلاد
لكنه بات اول رئيس وزراء يعزل من منصبه عن
طريق حجب الثقه برلمانيا في ابريل الماضي
بعد عشرات الانشقاقات عن حزبه حركه انصاف
حيث صوت 174 نائبا لصالح حدث الثقه عن
حكومه من مجموع
342 نائبا هم كل اعضاء البرلمان
الباكستاني اتهم عمران خان الولايات
المتحده بالتواطئ مع معرضه للاطاحه به
لانه يرفض تاييد السياسات واشنطن في
مواجهه روسيا والصين ومنذ الاطاحه به وحتى
محاوله اغتياله عصر الخميس يواصل عمران
خان قياده مظاهرات حارشده لاصاله احتجاجا
على الاطاحه به ومطالبا بانتخابات مبكرا
[موسيقى]
الى تطورات الحربي في اوكرانيا حيث قال
المجلس الاقليمي في خرسان ان القوات
الروسيه اوقفت عملها في المبنى الحكوميه
الرئيسيه في المدينه واشارت مصادر محليه
الى ان عدد القوات الروسيه في خرسان انخفض
في الاونه الاخيره مع نقل بعض الياتها الى
ضفه نهر النيبر والجنوبيه على دفاعات
صغيره فقلت مصادر الروسيه اوكرانيه ان
القوات الروسيه تواصل تفكيك المنشات
والمعدات الطبيه والمتاحف في خرسانيه
قادره على السعاده من روسيا وان
الاوكرانيين ايضا يؤمنون بذلك
المقابله اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه صدام
محاوله هجوميه اوكرانيه في خرسون وتدميرها
مستودعا للاسلحه في المقاطعه واسقاط
مروحيه عسكريه اوكرانيه وقال المتحدث باسم
الوزاره ايغور كولشينكوف ان القوات
الروسيه تصدت محاولات تقدم اوكرانيه عند
محوريمان في دونيسك والحقت خسائر بالقوات
المهاجره
الاوكرانيه التي خسرته هناك اكثر من 200
جندي وجرح اكثر من 200 اخرين وفي جنوب
القوه الاخرانيه
لكن تم ايقافها وقتل نحو 80 منهم كما تم
سد محاولات هجوم للقوات الاوكرانيه
فردا تقريبا كما اسقطت مروحيه عسكريه
اوكرانيه واعتراض صواريخ
والاستراتيجي ينضم لنا من بيروت عم يتحنا
هل نضج ما يحضر لخرصوم
جلال هناك مؤشرات مهمه جدا من الجانب
الروسي يعني المستشفيات الاخلاء انزال
العلم ولكن هناك في المقابل تعزيزات
عسكريه والسؤال الكبير دائما هل فعلا
الرئيس بوتين سيؤتي الرئيس لينسكي في احرج
الاوقات الضغط الداخلي والضغط الدولي نصرا
جديدا يضاف الى ما حصل في خارف يعني هذا
الامر وهذا ما عبر عنه الرئيسكي عندما قال
هناك خديعه تحضر للجيش الاوكراني في خرسون
وكانه اليوم تسعى القوات الروسيه الى قتال
في المدن قتال شوارع كما حصل في ماريو بول
وذلك لاستنزاف الجيش الاوكراني وبالتالي
تجميده وتثبيته لعدم القيام بعمليه عسكريه
في اماكن اخرى ولكن الباب مفتوح يبقى
الطقس متى واين وكيف
اتبعنا تصريحات اوستن وزير الدفاع
الامريكي يقول بان الاوكرانيين يعتقد بان
الاوكرانيين قادرون على استعاده خرسان كيف
تفهم هذه التصريحات بهذا المرحله
بالطبع يعني دائما عندما يكون هناك تعتيم
اعلامي من جهه الرئيسكي او القوات
الاوكرانيه يبدو ان هناك تحضير معينا كما
حصل في خاركاب يوم الوزير همم الهويدا
اوستن هم اعدوا لهذه العده ولكن هذا الامر
يتطلب وقتا ويتطلب جهودا اكثر واعتقد
اليوم في المرحله الحاليه بدا الجيش
الاوكراني يعاني من مصاعب الطقس هذه
المنطقه جلال هي منطقه زراعيه سهله المهم
هي قنوات الراي فيها وهمم كثيره ومتقاطعه
مع بعضها البعض هي تعطي اولويه للمناوره
ولكنها في نفس الوقت يعمل احد اهم العقبات
الاساسيه تحدثت عن معاناه الجيش الاوكراني
هل هذا ينسحب على الجبهه الشرقيه ايضا
لانه منذ فتره طويله لم نسمع بتقدم للجيش
الاوكراني في مناطق كان يتقدم قبل بشكل
اسرع ما الاسباب
الاسباب دائما هناك نقطه الذروه كما يقال
جلال يعني انت الامتداد الاقصى هناك قدر
معين من القوات ومن العتاد اذا صرت لفتره
طويله او الامتداد الاقصى او الاوفر
ستريتش كما يقال بالانجليزيه تصل الى
مرحله لا يمكن التقدم فيها اليوم المحور
المحور الشرقي هو بين صفاته وبين
الكريمينا او الخط الاساسي السريع قال 66
او بي 66 شكرا لك العميد الياس حنا في
بيروت
[موسيقى]
في ملف تصعيد اخر اكد وزير الدفاع الكوريه
الجنوبيه تعزيز التعاون الامنيه
والمناورات بين بلادي والولايات المتحده
للرد على الاستفزازات الكوريه الشماليه
تصريحات تاتي في يوم شهيد اطلاق عده
صواريخ وكان مسؤولون في كوريا الجنوبيه
واليابان قالوا في وقت سابق ان كوريا
الشماليه اطلقت صاروخ بالسيا عابرا
للقارات وسلاح الاطول مدى لديها ومصمم
لحمل راس نوويه الى الجانب الاخر من الارض
لكن عمليه اطلاق فشلت في المرحله الثانيه
صواريخ وبالستيه ومنورات عسكريه مدد
وتصريحات مهدده متبادله داخل الكوريتين
وحولهما لحربه ولا السلام صواريخ من
الشماليه تعبر الجنوبيه وتثير المخاوف في
اليابان تقول صول انبيون اطلقت الخميس
مالا يقل عن ثلاثه صواريخ قبل هذا التطور
بيوم اطلقت كوريا الشماليه خلال 24 ساعه
اكثر من 20 صاروخا سقط احدهم قرب المياه
الاقليميه للجاره الجنوبيه
رويتها ان تكون عمليه اطلاقه بقت بالفشل
وبان الاخفاق وقع خلال المرحله الثانيه من
عمليه انفصال الصاروخ المعلومات التي
قدمتها الصولد توضح ان الصاروخ يبلغ مداه
نحو 760 كلم
وارتفاعه اكثر من 1000 و900 كيلومتر بسرعه
15 مخ
التعاون العسكري بين الصور واشنطن سيزيد
ويتواصل وفق كلامي وزير الدفاع الكوري
الجنوبي خلال زيارته للولايات المتحده
الاستفزازات الكوريه الشماليه
منوراتها العسكريه المشتركه
سميت المناورات التي بدات في الحج
والثلاثين من اكتوبر الماضي العاصفه
للقضاء هي الاكبر من نوعها وتشارك فيها
مئات الطائرات الحربيه منها الاف 35
المنوره استفزازيه بنظري بيونغ التي صعدت
نبرتها بالصواريخ والكلام وحذرت من انه في
حال استمرار المناورات ستواجه الولايات
المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه
في التاريخ
الخوف دفع طوكيو الى اطلاق سافرات الانذار
بالخطا صححت لاحقا وذره الدفاع مقالته
الحكومه الصاروخ الكوري الشمالي لم يحلق
فوق اجزاء من اليابان
اوضح رئيس الوزراء فوم يوكيدا في تصريح
مقتضب بعد التمديد دعت واشنطن كل الدول
الى تعزيز العقوبات المفروضه على نظام
الرئيسي كيم جونغ اون اعتبرت اطلاق صاروخ
باليستيك عابر للقارات انتهاكا لقرارات
مجلس الامن لكن القادمه قد يكون الاخضر
والاكثر رعبا ماذا لو صدقت التكهنات
المزدوجه للصلب واشنطن التي تتحدث عن
استعدادات بيونغ يونغ لاجراء التجربه
النوويه جديده ستكون السابعه في تاريخها
السناده المتخصصين في شان الكوري الان هو
عاده احداث تسبق احتفال كوريا الشماليه
قبل تجربتها انه بي المقبله
[موسيقى]
القمه العربيه في الجزائر بوعود واحلام
كثيره كبيره حملها شعاره قمه لم الشمل لكن
الواقع العربي يقدم بيئه سياسيه واقتصاديه
تجعل من ادراك هذه الاحلام امرا عسيرا فلا
تزال الازمات السياسيه في كثير من الدول
العربيه بما فيها تلك التي تتمتع بموارد
ضخمه مثل العراق وليبيا والسودان وربما
تكون مساله الاذان بنصوص مبادره السلام
العربيه مع اسرائيل بيانا اخر في عدم
اجتماع الاراده العربيه على موقف واحد من
اسرائيل وكل ذلك يجعل لما الشمل حلما ليس
الجميع سواء في الايمان به فضلا عن الاخذ
بها فوزيه
قمه لم الشمل في الجزائر بدات كما لو انها
استدبار لواقع ما كان فيه الشمل مستمعه
وهو قليل ما كان لكن في شعار القمه بعد
امل ينتظر ان تصدق الافعال وعوده السخيه
بعالم تتحقق فيه احلام المواطن العربي في
الحريه والعيش الكريم
ولا يكون ذلك ممكنا حتى تفارق القمه
الطريقه الذي سلكته قيمه سابقات ما كان
حصادها غير البيانات غير المبينات في
العمل والفعل
كان هناك اجماع في قمه الجزائر عبر عنه
معظم وخطابات القاده العرب حول عديد من
القضايا في مقدمتها الالتزام التام
بمبادره العربيه للسلام مع اسرائيل
واساسها السلام مقابل الارض بما يمكن من
قيام دوله فلسطينيه عاصمتها القدس على
حدود الرابع من يونيو حزيران من عام 67
واكد القاده على تعزيز العمل العربي
المشترك ونادرا ما كان لضمان الامن
الغذائي في عالم اصبحت بعض ادواته في
الحرب الغذاء والطاقه واكد البيانو على
ضروره التماسك المنظومه العربيه ووحدتها
في تعاطيها مع العالم الخارجي ولان العالم
العربي كثير لعلل فقد اخذت القمه على
نفسها مساعده الدول على التعافي مما هي
فيه من احتراب وازمات سياسيه وهي ليبيا
وسوريا واليمن والعراق والسودان والصومال
الى غيرها من الدول العربيه بيت ان طموحات
قمه لم الشمل ستصطدم بما كرسه الواقع من
معطيات يمضي اكثرها على عكس ما تريد القمه
فقضيه السلامه التي هو الطبيع في مفرده
اخرى تشترط وفق المبادره العربيه استعاده
الارض ومن ثم يصوره الى السلامك نتيجه
الحتميه هذه القضيه تبدو فرضيه يسخر منها
الواقع فهناك دول طبعت هي دوله الامارات
العربيه المتحده ومملكه البحرين والمملكه
المغربيه والسودان فلحقت هذه الدول بدول
سالمت اسرائيل على طريقتها هي مصر والاردن
وهذا معطل يصيب المبادره في مقتل الا ان
يعود الجميع مسلمين ومطبعين فيتحلل من كل
اتفاق ويلزم انفسهم بالمبادره العربيه
وبمنطق لم الشمل فلا تكون ثمه غانم قاسيات
ياكلهن
اما الامن الغذائي الذي يراد له ان يكون
السودان باراضيه الفسيحه الخصيبه ومياه
الوفيره ماظن انك تحققه فهو مطلب يعصر
انجازه في المستقبل المنظور فاسودال يخوض
غمار ازمه سياسيه لا يعرف احد ما يكون من
نتائجه
والقاعده الاقتصاديه تقول
لاستثمار ولا زراعه في ظل الحرب وامرات
الامن الاجتماعيه
بين وفره المال عند بعض الدول وبين وفره
الموارد الطبيعيه لدى الاخرى للارتقاء
بحياه المواطن العربي واقتلاء الفقر من
حياته وليس العمر العربي السياسي المشترك
باقل مشقه وصعوبه من العمل الاقتصادي
فالحم بوحده الاراده العربيه الجماعيه
لاداره العلاقه مع العالم الخارجي يتبدد
بنهايه القمه وطي اوراقها ولذلك من مص في
بيان القمه على حق العالم العربي في اي
يكون فاعلا في صياغه هياكل النظام العالمي
الجديد في عالم ما بعد كرونا وعالمي ما
بعد الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا قد يبدو
منطقيا لامه يبلغ تعدادها ما يقرب من 450
مليون نسمه يتوزعون على جغرافيه تتوسط
العالم وتطل على بحاره وممراته المائيه
الاستراتيجيه في مساحه تزيد على ثلاثه
عشره مليون كيلو متر مربع لكنه معطيات هذه
القوه لا تكاد تتجسد ظهورا استراتيجيا
عالميا يؤبه له ذلك قبول القوه الحديثه
ولم الشمل وحده قد لا يخرجك من القوه حتى
تتوافر اسباب تحريرها قيل ما هي
الديمقراطيه والحريه والكرامه
[موسيقى]
طبيا نتابع حيث اعلنت شركه بيونتيك وفايزر
لصناعه الادويه انهما بدات دراسه لانتاج
لقاح الموحد ضد فيروس كورونا والانفلونزا
المنتشره كثيرا في هذا الوقت وقالت
الشريكتان في بيان ان الجرعه الواحده هي
مزيج من اللقاح المضاد للانفلونزا واللقاح
المعزز ضد كورونا المصمم خصيصا ضد متحور
اوميكرون وكيلهما من انتاج شركه فايزر
واضافت الشركتان ان الدراسه التي لا تزال
في مراحلها الاولى تهدف الى تقييم سلامه
الجرعه المركبه على الاشخاص ومقدار
الحمايه المناعيه كما اشارته الى ان
التجارب ستجري في الولايات المتحده على
100 و80 متطوره
اعلنت عده دول اوروبيه اليوم ارتفاع عدد
الاصابات والوفيات جراء فايروس كورونا ففي
المانيا اعلن تسجيل اكثر من 78 الف اصابه
جديده بالفايروس خلال 24 ساعه فضلا عن 200
واحد وثمان وفاه كما سجلت اليونان اكثر من
53.000 اصابه
و176 وفاء خلال الساعه 24 الماضيه وفي
اسيا اعلنت اليابان تسجيلا نحو
67,000,500 اصابه جديده
هذه الاخبار تعيدنا قليلا للحديث عن
كورونا لنتذكر معا عن قصه هذه الجائحه منذ
بدايتها قبل ثلاث سنوات في ايام العام
ابلغت اللجنه الصحيه في مدينه الصينيه عن
حالات اصابه بالتهاب رئوي سرعان متاكد
انها اصابات بفيروس كورونا المستجد ارتعب
العالم من اخبار سريع الانتشار ما بين
مصدقا ومكذب لكن سرعان ما ظهرت اول اصابه
بكورنا خارج الصين وكانت في تايلاند ثم
توالت الاخبار لتعلن دوله واخرى اكتشاف
اول حاله ثم حالات ويعم الفيروس القرى
الارضيه عندها انطبق على المرض توصيف
الجارحه العالميه وسرعان ما اعلنت الدول
سلسله اجراءات احترازيه واغلاقات لم
يشهدها
التاريخ عطا الله الامل بعد ذلك ففي اغسطس
اعلنت روسيا عن اول لقاح للمرض باسمي
سبوتنيك تبعه في ديسمبر اعلان امريكي عن
لقاح فايزر بيونتك ثم سينوفارم الصيني
واسرى ذلك البريطاني ومديرنا ايضا
الامريكي لكن الازمه لم تنتهي فقط تكشف
الفايروس عن طفارات
وسلالات متلاحقه فاقمت العدوى ورفعت اعداد
الموتى والمصابين عبر العالم وسط مخاوف من
تقويد فاعليه اللقاحات المكتشفه واليوم
نسبيا بات كل ما تحدثنا عنه ذكرى اليمه من
الماضي خاصه لاولئك الذين فقدوا احبائهم
وانقلبت اوضائهم راسا على عقب
حديث الخسائر مؤلم بطبيعه الحال اذ اصابت
الجائحه بحسب احدث بيانات جامعه جوزهوب
كنز الامريكيه
631 مليون شخص في العالم توفي منهم اكثر
من سته ملايين ونصف المليون اما خسائر
الاقتصاد العالمي فقدرها صندوق النقد
الدولي بنحو 15 تريليون دولار حتى نهايه
2000 و 2024 بما يعادل اثنين في المئه
وثمانيه اعشار في المئه من اجمالي الناتج
العالم قبل الحصاد كنت قد اجريت مقابله مع
الدكتور انطوني المستشار الطبي الاول
للرئيس الامريكي ومدير المعهد الوطني
للحساسيه والامراض المعديه سالته اولا عن
تحذيره من متحور جديد قد يجعل هذا الشتاء
صعبه
وضيع النمر
الاصليه 45 التي نقلق بشانها في الولايات
المتحده وفي العالم احدها بي كيو بوينت 1
والثاني
والاخر هو اكس بي بي لديهما ميزه في
الانتقال اكبر من المتحولات الاصليه وهي
قد تتغلب على المقاومه وتنتشر بطريقه اكثر
كفاءه من بي اي 45 من حسن الحظ ان الجرعات
المتاحه الان لتقويه تملك القدره على ان
تحفز الرد الذي يحمل منها ولهذا السبب من
المهم تلقي اللقاح وعلى من لم يحصل على
جرعه المعززه ان يحصل عليها
ما هي توصيتكم لمواجهه متحور جديد في ال
ال الشتاء المقبل
هي ان يتلقى اكبر عدد من الناس اللقاح لان
الفرق في العدوى والانتقال ونسبه الوفاه
اكبر بكثير لدى من لم يتلقى اللقاح مقارنه
وهذا السبب وجيه بينما ندخل للاشهر
البارده في اواخر فصل الخريف والشتاء بان
نواكب مستجدات اللقاح
المدير العام للنظله الصحه العالميه قال
قبل فتره ان العالم اقرب من اي وقت مضى
للقضاء على وباء كورونا
اذا ما قررنا هذا الكلام مع ما تقوله انت
الان عن احتماليه وجود متحور جديد كيف
نفهم هذا
وجهتين نظر لان المدير العام لمنظمه الصحه
اذا نظرنا الى وضعنا الان مقارنه بالعام
الماضي عندما ظهر ميكرون للمره الاولى
فالان نحن في وضع الافضل بكثير رغم انه
هناك متحورات جديده الا ان مستوى العدوى
اقل بكثير عن العام الماضي في نفس الوقت
نقوم بجهود اكثر والكثير من الناس يتلقون
اللقاح مثلا عندما كان او ميكرون في ذروته
في الولايات المتحده كان هناك تقريبا من
800,000 الى 900,000 اصابه وعدى جديده
يوميا وكذلك من ثلاثه الاف
حاله وفاه اليوم لدينا من 350 الى 40 100
حاله وفاه رغم هذا نعتقد انه مستوى غير
مقبول ونريده ان يقل اكثر كلنا نواجه
التحدي بوجود متحورات جديده لكن كما ذكرت
لدينا عالميه دوليه للوقايه من هذه
المتحورات وهذا عن طريق الحرص على تلق
اللقاء
19 طويل الاجل هل يشكل تحديات اضافيه
بنسبه لكم
وهذه قضيه مهمه جدا لانه على سبيل المثال
في الولايات المتحده وهي بلد كبير بكثافه
سكانيه عاليه لدينا تقريبا من سبعه الى 15
مليون شخص مصاب بكوه طويل الاجل وهو عباره
عن استمرار للاعراض لاسابيع او لاشهر بعد
التعافي من المرحله الحاده للمرض ولدينا
مليون شخص غير قادر على العمل بسبب تاثرهم
بذلك لذلك نحن نركز على هذا الامر ويعتبر
متلازمه غامضه لاننا لا نعرف كل الاليات
المتعلقه به لكننا ندرسه عن كثب لنرى ان
كنا قادرين على منعه قوي التعامل معه
ومعالجه المصابين به
الدكتور فوزي لماذا تعتبر بانه يجب
التعامل مع جدري القرده بشكل اكثر صرامه
لاننا نريد ان نضمن الا ينتشر بشكل اكبر
فهو قضيه المتفاعله والان لدينا تقريبا
28,000 شخص في الولايات المتحده مصاب
بجدري القرده نريد ان نضمن السيطره على
هذا المرض بتقديم الادويه واللقاح من
المهم جدا التعامل مع هذا المرض لانه خارج
افريقيا ينتشر بين الرجال الذين يمارسون
الجنس مع الرجال ونريد تنبيها هذه الفئه
اما جداريه القرده ينتشر بينهم ونريدهم ان
يتلقوا اللقاح لانه متوفر دكتور السؤال
الاخير ربما ينتشر الان ما يعرف بالار اس
بي الفيروسات التنفسيه ويدخل الكثير من
الاطفال الى المستشفيات وربما الى العنايه
الفائقه هل بعد الجائحه وبعد التباعد
الاجتماعي لفتره طويله اصبحنا اكثر عرضه
للاصابه بالفيروسات التنفسيه
احدى المشكلات انه عندما كان الكثيرون
يرتدون الكمامه ويتباعدون اجتماعيا انخفضت
الكثير من الامراض التنفسيه والتلاشت الان
يخرج الناس ولا يستخدمون الكمامات
ويشاركون في مناسبات اجتماعيه لذلك نشهد
زياده في هذه الامراض وهي امراض نراها في
منتصف الشتاء لكن بدنا نراها الان في
منتصف الخريف حتى قبل قدوم الشتاء هذا امر
مقلق جدا لان الفيروسات المسببه
الالتهابات الجهاز التنفسي قد تكون خطيره
على الاطفال دون خمس سنوات وعلى المسنين
لذلك يجب ان نتعامل معها بشكل حذر
ونستخدمه كل الاجراءات الاحترازيه التي
نستخدمها مع سائر الامراض التنفسيه
شكرا لك دكتور انطوني فوتشي مدير معهد
الوطني للحساسيه والامراض المعديه
المستشار الطبيه الاول للرئيس الامريكي
جوبادر شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
نتوقف عند قصه هذه الشابه وهي المانيه
تدعى مارلين انجل هون كانت محظوظه فوارثت
الملايين الخبر لم يجعلها سعيده وانما
قالت بالحرف انها منزعجه للغايه من هذه
الثروه وتريد التخلص منها بالكامل منطلق
مارلين كان حديثا يتعلق بالعداله
الاجتماعيه تقول انها لا تؤمنوا لان احداث
ينبغي ان يمتلك هذا القدر من القوه
والاموال المعاشات من الضرائب وهي التي لم
تكسبه بعرق جبينها منطق مثالي قد يبدو صعب
التطبيق لكنه من الجميل ان يكون هناك اناس
يفكرون في الاخرين وفي تو بتاع الخبزه على
الجميع نهت الحصاد شكرا المتابعه الى
اللقاء لان الله ورعايته
[موسيقى]